[Music]
everyone thinks of wyoming it's the
cowboy state so you know you think of
open land cattle and cowboys they want
it to be open land cattle cowboys and
crypto this 40-acre plot of land in
northwestern wyoming has a new owner a
group of around 6 000 crypto investors
whose goal is to build a city using the
ethereum blockchain we're imagining this
kind of future where you know you see
this beautiful parcel map of all the
different pieces of land in one click
basically just buy this nft and you now
have the right to use that land this
group of investors is called city dao
and it has no official leader rather
it's owned and governed by its members
we are collectively governing this land
so we're deciding what happens to the
land if you know we're going to build
things if we're going to you know allow
people to camp on the land this type of
organization is known as a dao there are
about 200 tracked by the data service
deep dow and they all have different
goals like collectively owning an nba
team a rare copy of the us constitution
or a future blockchain-based city so how
exactly do daos work why have they
become a part of wyoming real estate and
what risks come with investing in them
dao stands for decentralized autonomous
organization think about a mutual fund
which is an investment product created
by a company the company maintains it
the company is responsible for managing
all the money for deciding what the
mutual funds purpose is what its goal is
but unlike a mutual fund dows don't have
a company or any leader to make these
decisions instead members pool money
together and decide as a group how they
want to spend it usually once members
buy in they receive a token which grants
them voting rights all of the dow's
functions are also written into code on
the blockchain think about an investment
vehicle where all the components of the
investment vehicle
are written into a piece of software and
launched and nobody actually owns it and
it runs out on its own unlike a
traditional corporate structure where
the company looks for investors to raise
money dows let people find them through
the internet the real sort of ingenious
idea behind this isn't necessarily that
you've come up with some new way to make
money it's that you've come up with a
new way to find investors citi dow
became the first dow to own land thanks
to a new law in wyoming that went into
effect last july the law recognizes daos
as llcs and llcs can own real estate
wyoming passed this law because wyoming
legislators a couple of years ago
decided that blockchain could give the
state a competitive advantage and they
wanted to try to attract
blockchain-based businesses wyoming has
passed a number of laws to make it
easier for blockchain-based companies to
operate out of the state one of which
exempts cryptocurrency from state tax
inspired by the wyoming dow law scott
fitzsimmons started city dow in the
hopes that eventually people could buy
land instantaneously and those
transactions would be transparent for
all to see on the blockchain if you were
to go want to buy
or build something on a piece of land in
wyoming right now you would have to go
to you know loop net you'd have to go
explore different pieces of land you'd
have to go on craigslist and try to you
know call people and work out a deal
sign some papers maybe mail something it
would just be a very cumbersome tiresome
product fitzsimmons says citi dao has
raised around 7 million dollars from its
membership since it was founded last
july members include brian armstrong the
co-founder of coinbase and vitalik
buterin co-creator of the ethereum
network to join city dow you have to buy
a citizen nft which currently sells for
about 0.4 ethereum which is around 1 000
once you're a citizen you have the right
to vote on proposals and propose your
own ideas for example we had citizens
already passed a proposal to get drone
footage of the land in january city dow
released a new batch of nfts for
citizens to purchase each one represents
a lease to a specific plot of land in
wyoming so imagine city dao llc owns
this property but you know we basically
encode a
lease as an nft and say you have the
right to use this parcel build on this
parcel fitzsimon says they intend to
treat this parcel as a test run and that
they're already looking at locations for
their next purchase he says the next one
will be in a less remote area so
citizens can have the option to build on
the land perhaps there's some future
where we start you know living there
living close to each other building
things on the land he also says city dao
is looking into buying land outside
wyoming we would still use the wyoming
llc and technically wyoming overseas can
own land anywhere but there are
certainly some nuances to how that is um
you know how that works
dows are still considered an
experimental business model even as
awareness grows i think dows are going
to remain limited i think the idea is
very intriguing i think you will see a
lot of attempted experimentation people
are going to try it out see where it
fits but i think
for the time being it's going to be
really hard to do one of these on a very
very large scale one dow that made
headlines in november was constitution
dow it tried to buy a rare first edition
copy of the us constitution raising over
40 million dollars in less than a week
that's just one example of how dows can
raise a lot of capital very quickly but
this also makes them a big target for
hacking when you're doing this
ultimately everything now becomes
dependent upon the software if it was
not written well and it collects a lot
of money somebody's gonna figure out a
way to hack it and get into it i mean
even
even well-written software programs can
be hacked and because most dows
communicate through the messaging
platform discord security there is a
growing area of concern as well on
january 10th someone hacked into a city
dow administrator's account on discord
and scammed some members into sending
them tens of thousands of dollars
fitzsimon said that after the incident
city dao did a full review and increased
security on its server he added that
this type of attack has been happening
to several dow servers a spokeswoman
from discord says the company is working
to prevent scams by investing
significant resources in education and
tools that protect its users the lack of
a traditional corporate structure could
also make it harder for individual
investors to hold dows accountable when
it comes to fraud scams and abuse this
is a
very risky
very nascent space
and
most of the people who are in it sort of
understand those risks and are willing
to take them the sec says it wants to
bring the digital currency market under
its investor protection framework
meanwhile dow enthusiasts like
fitzsimmons are hopeful that dows will
improve and grow over time eventually
you know people will kind of realize the
you know existing system of like it
takes you know a month to buy a piece of
you know land of property that will seem
really crazy so i i definitely imagine
more and more land and assets coming on
to blockchain and you know city down
being there when that happens and you
know helping make it all possible
[Music]